greenpeace on l'a fait une spécialité
les actions coup de poing pour une
couverture médiatique la plus large
possible
mais ordonne de quitter les lieux sous
peine d'une
un manque considérable de canicule on
n'arrive plus à refroidir les centrales
on rejette dans les rivières de l'eau
très chaude qui a un vrai problème
environnemental pour les associations de
protection de l'environnement
l'innocuité des ogm n'a pas été
suffisamment de monfreid si on considère
qu'il ya des risques potentiels et ben
il faut appliquer le principe de
précaution deux militants de greenpeace
prennent d'assaut le clemenceau qu'il
juge hautement toxiques
la société qui à désamianter le
clemenceau à toulon le considèrent
qu'ils n'ont encore 500 à 1000 tonnes
d'amiante avoir dû commensaux 7 heures
du matin autour du rainbow warrior la
bataille navale peut commencer lebara
pêcheur lance nord zodiac sur ceux de
greenpeace sur place la gendarmerie
maritime n'intervient pas
c'est complètement fou c'est que ils
nous balancent des boulots que la
gendarmerie est là à 100 mev et qu'elle
ne fait absolument rien alors qu'elle
était parfaitement prévu prévenu que les
thoniers senneurs allait faire cette
action après un moratoire de 14 ans
l'islande a repris depuis hier la chasse
à la baleine il n'y a absolument pas
besoin de tuer des cétacés pour les
étudier beaucoup d'animation devant la
base militaire de l'île longue après un
jeu de cache cache avec le commando de
marine trois écologistes pénètre dans
les eaux de la base à bord d'un zodiac
pour les contrevenants l'action est
symbolique le directeur des campagnes de
greenpeace france l'a rappelé
aujourd'hui en correctionnelle le
procureur qu'il n'entend pas ainsi a
requis pour chaque prévenu trois mois de
prison avec sursis une amende de 2000
euros ainsi que la confiscation du
zodiaque d'une valeur de 50 mille euros
ce coup d'éclat en zodiac pour avoir
tenté de pénétrer dans la base nucléaire
sous-marine de l'ile-longue vous vaudra
une condamnation pour atteinte aux
intérêts supérieurs de la nation yannick
jadot la fin justifie t'elle tous les
moyens pas tous les moyens un jamais la
violence jamais la violence contre des
personnes jamais la destruction des
biens mais il ya une violence parfois
non non non pas chez greenpeace
c'est justement les activistes sont
formés entraînés pour éviter justement
toute forme de violence parce que ça
cela remettrait en cause la légitimité
de la dénonciation qui est fait à ce
moment là mais on voit bien c'est vrai
que nous avons arraché des ogm avec avec
josé bové et beaucoup d'autres c'était
illégal mais ça correspondait et ça
correspond toujours souhaits des
citoyens et maintenant c'est dans la loi
on peut pas produire peut pas cultiver
des ogm en france donc la loi la
légalité
c'est aussi une construction politique
c'est une construction citoyenne et
parfois des actions peuvent
faire évoluer la loi dans le sens de
l'intérêt général parce qu'il ya des
nouvelles menaces par là et c'est ça le
c'est sale rôle de greenpeace c'est ça
le rôle aujourd'hui dell 214 c'est
totalement illégal d'aller filmer dans
des abattoirs qui sont fermés mais ça
participe de la prise de conscience ça
participe de l'évolution de la
réglementation et pour le coup là
la suppression de la souffrance animale
donc c'est une bonne chose
[Musique]